hi everyone I'm David Griffin now
Michael Medina we're here to bring you
our video game of the year 2013 if it
was a little too early good screw those
in for every way of 2014 you better late
than never earlier than ever made you
are every game of the year Mike and I a
few months ago did a video game of the
year so far yeah and a lot of some
people got on us about salable Batman's
not out you know where Theft Auto [ __ ]
total five wasn't out yet so of course
we're just speculating about what could
be I still think at the end of the year
the two the weird thing is at that point
I gotta stop there Mike I didn't play in
the arcade games the other of us had yet
to play it I mean are kidding me not
triple-a Not Call of Duty not Batman not
not yet the thoughtless caller stuff the
smaller stuff so i think when we started
getting into the tension is by surprise
yeah you know high quality games yes you
know that were simple but yet very
intuitive right so instead of starting
with some of our games let's start with
maybe GTA 5 since that's the big one
that ever i was talking about in firstly
for me GTA 5 is good was big and
brilliant and just perfectly executed no
lag no let me know loading screens kind
of forgot about it after I played it I
beat it and then kind of left it alone
like what was your thought 15 I agree
that's one of the problems I've always
had with a grand theft auto I first of
all I love Grand Theft Auto my played
every single one I play grand theft auto
5 loved it um the thing with Grand Theft
Auto as a series as a whole it does get
a little repetitive after a while
because it really is essentially the
same thing it's almost like I've been
there done that you know like you know
kill some prostitutes you know okay you
rob some banks steals a car that's a
little mean now granted this particular
game definitely up the ante on a lot I
mean the world itself is huge it was a
solid story great beer here there's a
great threat voice acting right it was
an amazing game but at the end it's like
once I was done with the main story I
found myself only going back maybe a
handful of times really a little online
and a little of like some of the stuff I
missed her in a single player campaign
but then I was like all right kind of
you know ready to play something else
and I haven't gone back since yeah and
it's hard to fault it because it's it
did exactly what we thought it was gonna
do and I hate I'm almost I am faulted on
that which is bad because it's such a
well-executed game at together so well
great oh yeah I mean yeah this mean
doubt did call Judy I think this
just made so much money and I mean it's
but it's like it just it felt like I'm
like it did what I expected to do yeah
that's what it was and I guess what to
leave it at that but again an excellent
game glad we got to play it great game
another one of my other favorite games
this year i know you and i both had a
chance to play was batman arkham origins
other than that when we did our previous
review we couldn't talk about it it
wasn't out yet now it is a good game
maybe kind of like GTA did what you
expect it to do yeah exactly i think for
me personally arkham asylum I'm sorry
Arkham City it was so great and so close
in my eyes to perfection that when I
play this it was it was more the same
well I definitely didn't up the ante the
way like Arkham City did compared to
Arkham Asylum right you know and that's
not a bad thing definitely it's not you
know it was good right you know there's
nothing wrong with it just like the
story itself takes place obviously in
the early days of Bruce's careers Batman
and stuff and that was cool to see that
I just think maybe the story could have
been told a little bit well better i
think it just kind of like throws you
into like all right yeah Batman I would
like some kind of we all know his
backstory but I would have liked some
kind of introduction to why this is
happening again another like GTA again
we're kind of talking about our runners
up here kind of games that we really
enjoyed but we're gonna get to our game
of the year at the end and i think it's
it's when those games it did exactly
what we thought i was gonna do like GTA
and legs pretty look later smoothest
fighting mechanics of all three but
again it just didn't deliver anything
new yeah you know it really did feel
like more the same because you would
revisit the same environments that you
saw in Arkham City you know just covered
in snow right yeah i mean and i mean
great voice acting again I mean Troy
Baker is on a roll I mean his Joker's
pretty good this joke I've heard about
mark hamill's he's a good mark hamill
impression um yes yeah which is good I
hope if you're gonna if you're gonna
steal and steal from the best I think
yeah Troy Baker obviously with Last of
Us and bioshock infinite he's just a man
so you know moving on let's talk about a
game that you and I were split on this
was almost my game of the year very
close but it just didn't quite cut it
BioShock Infinite this is a game this
caused a lot of controversy the ending
which we won't spoil here as this you
know people been talking about it for a
long time like what is it
you know cool ending but like you know
what were you thoughts about on bioshock
infinite well okay to be fair okay I've
only played half of bioshock 1 i never
played bioshock 2 but i did play
infinite definitely hands down one of
the prettiest games i've ever seen right
no doubt about it I felt that from a
story perspective it was a little dull
at times for whatever reason and this is
part of the problem i had with bioshock
1 I don't like the way they tell a story
you know it'll give me an example halo
for example tell us an amazing story
they do a great job of making you
immersion you in this world right you
know and I felt like at times BioShock
Infinite was very repetitive right you
know I felt no desire to continue like
why am i doing what I'm doing why is
this happening you know what I mean now
the ending was kind of made up for all
that because I thought it was really
interesting I would have appreciated a
lot more and I played the previous two
right you know but it was cool ending
yeah you know what I mean but overall
was not memorable I played it once and I
had no desire to play it again right
yeah now for me was like obviously this
game too because blew my mind just all
over the place I just loved I loved the
first one second one more the same
didn't do anything new but still
enjoyable about right infinite to me it
was just probably just one of my
favorite games I've ever plays on my
most enjoyable experiences I played it
like three times and I just loved the
story it's just out there it's like I
don't want to spoil anything because if
you haven't played at all it's just I
can't talk about too much but the world
you notice the the city in the sky is
opposed to a huge world a huge very
crazy oh well imagine it's just
something you've never really seen like
when you first kind of push those doors
open like that you just see the city its
just oh it's incredible they talk about
like racism and like feminist movements
and national national pride issues like
all this stuff separation secession from
like the United States all this cool
stuff mixed with some really weird time
thing so I won't spoil that but another
one I was one of my favorite games
almost got my game of the year let's
talk about something that's not what
some ladies I one lady in particular who
I would never used to be interested in
that who I just thought had excuse my
language but had you know big boobs and
some small shorts and that's about the
extent of what she was well talk about
hawara or Lara Lara Lara are we going to
prepare a Croft tumor the reinvention of
tomb raider by square enix this year i
mean that
pretty incredible yeah absolutely and I
felt maybe not as strong as you did
about about Lara Croft but definitely
her games were always the control
mechanics were a little weird to me I
wanted to love this game back like in
her heyday yeah I just couldn't get into
it decided give this game a try and was
blown away at how much I loved it you
know multiplayer really left a lot to be
desired I think I played it like once
and I was like yeah whatever i played
through the single story I don't even
know like five six times right I just
it's that good you know and I hate
comparing games to other games because I
mean there it's like apples and oranges
it's not fair to do but like I uncharted
yeah that's the first game that came to
mind and it's like I love love uncharted
so definitely I tried to see like just
compare like certain ailments like what
I loved about uncharted and what I loved
about tumor and I thought they were
pretty close i like the way they told
the story maybe not as strongly as like
naughty dog tells their stories right
but i thought it was good it was
believable yeah you know this struggle
that she's this young girl kind of
becoming a laura croft that we all know
and love but I think that's the thing
one thing with tumor little different
bar chart uncharted a little bit better
of a supporting cast you gotta care what
the characters I mean you know Laura had
her group of guys we just didn't really
care about him that much as opposed to
uncharted like all the coders are really
really interesting ensemble chest and
uncharted and it really is tomb Raider's
just about her the Jupiter's graphics
just gorgeous you know great looking
game again there's so many good looking
games this year and just exciting good
adventure story of course eating a Jones
thing the Uncharted thing you know but
it was good and it wasn't just a girl
with you know I mean she's pretty but
like she's a survivor we see that she's
a survivor first before we see the short
shorts and Angelina Jolie the sunrise so
anyway uh let's go now I guess let's get
to the game of the years these now I can
I both played our game with years we
have different game of the years but we
both played each other's game so am I
gonna get the floor to you first started
off talking about your game of the year
which is the last of us who what never
play that the smaller gay maybe I yeah
um hands down my game of the year this
game was damn near perfection to me I
mean from I don't even know where to
begin with the game like this it just it
the way the story was presented I mean
it's a story that we've all heard their
cut
it's not really zombies but it kind of
is it's like The Walking Dead or really
a good version of the walk yeah so we've
all heard these zombies stores but I
thought they did such an amazing job in
a believable job of telling this story
right you know the voice again with
naughty dog they just have a knack for
great storytelling amazing voice acting
graphics were gorgeous definitely some
of the best graphics you're gonna see on
the ps3 um one of my favorite moments in
this game and one of the reasons why i
love this game so much is a moment that
comes later on this and you're gonna see
it involves you know Ellie and your
animal yeah oh I seen that was very
touching and i thought was um is one of
those moments that kind of you know you
steps you kind of step out of this world
you remember just like what the world
was and what it is about it like you
know just humanity as a whole and stuff
and i thought that was really a touching
i want to talk about it so badly such a
great scene it was one of those games
that you can't it has stealth elements
some actions arrival or survival it's a
little bit of everything it's a melting
pot of all these these different genres
and stuff but they did it so well write
it was one of those things that was so
memorable definitely one of the best
experiences I've had playing video games
um and definitely one of those things
like one of those games where as soon as
I finished it I ran to play it again not
wait to play it again I think you know
you myself and Dennis of all kind of
been talking about how Sony towards the
end of this console generation ever get
into the xbox one and ps4 and all this
and steam boxes and all that kind of
stuff ps4 got it with their you know
what's the word with their not stand
alone but exclusive listed oh yeah with
their exclusive IPS they they they got
it I think a little bit better than xbox
yeah towards ya yeah I mean with the
last of us uncharted like three
everything is kept getting better and
better i mean the xbox has great titles
you love halo you know but we've seen my
how many times can master chief say the
day we've seen that but i mean last of
us always like really original titles
i'm sorry i can't God war-daughter order
the lattice tension was solid game right
now and then you know I mean even you
know Mike and I to mention another game
just to kind of mix into our game with
your talk is a beyond two souls yes was
a very interesting you know crazy game
yeah I'm the foe and I mean I was
actually kind like a runner-up for me is
definitely interesting game didn't know
what to expect with this game I mean I'd
played heavy rain right you know so I
figured I assumed it'd be similar it was
kind of but better right terms of just
like the gameplay mechanics yeah and
just the the facial expressions in the
acting so trying to get out here just
the ps3 is place it's only just kind of
got it at the end they got the there's
their ips their their their small game
are there I say exclusive it's not
smoking exclusive games better I can't
wait to see a sequel we got some dlc
coming out last of us on yeah
valentine's Day on Valentine's I got
some of that coma morals aside swear
with Ellie comic books i believe dark
horse comics as a comic book series
online so i mean you know all this great
stuff with a the game is coming up now
CTO yes we got a dlc coming out you know
you have on valentines day for the last
ones got deals he got a le side story
Dark Horse Comics has the series going
out right now it's gonna get some more
backstory on Ellie and her friend I mean
just so much good stuff with the last of
us coming out great game Sony's hitting
it to doing a great job right now
next-gen systems doing a great job so
we'll see you sony but into my game of
the year now that's how about the last
of us which mike played to this is
brothers a tale of two sons and after i
play this game as it might you gotta
play brothers you got to play but i
think Mike it was a sale on xbox you
know like I was doing like a sale and
you picked it up and it's funny because
I remember hearing about this game and
sing some videos like when it first came
out he was one of those games and like
yeah whatever didn't it didn't draw me
in bridge spoke so highly of it again
like I know what am I gonna did our
previous video of our game of the year
earlier and I was asking that was like
you know guys you have any like indie
games or a smaller non triple-a call
duty Batman big titles like that we
could play and brothers kept coming up a
lot of Game of the Year lists I'm like
what is this game so I played it got my
little xbox controller like one analog
stick moves one brother there knocks it
was the other brother and what I thought
mike is after I beat it I was like you
know I'm not gonna spoiling this is
really emotional moments in this game
this game is not for the faint of heart
is a heavy game I mean what with no
dialogue it's not like the Teletubbies
speak like a blob of abilene all that
kind of stuff and like the controller
itself by the end of the game no
spoilers like becomes a character yeah
because when you're controlling each
brother and its just oh it's it's
greatly good how would you describe it I
don't even know how to eat it it's hard
but that's it's a it's a good point to
bring up because there is a moment when
it really is just your controller that
conveys these emotions it sounds weird
like you get it what are you talking
about I'm gonna get that yeah it makes
perfect sense um it was a good game
maybe I just have a cold heart maybe I
wasn't as right like I I never cried in
the video game actually got teary-eyed
at some of the scenes in this video game
my how do you know no but no I totally
see what you mean because it definitely
is an emotional game in a game that's it
was a lot heavier than I thought I was
good these kids are like oh this guy you
know that's like what but it was really
well done so inventive some of the stuff
they had was the stuff that I had never
seen in a video game before right right
all from just like some little small
arcade game and that's what edged it out
food for Game of the Year love BioShock
Infinite we talked about beyond two
souls a little bit that's other game
that was on my one of my close runner-up
but at the end brothers just something I
never experienced before while playing a
game of the mechanics the platforming
some of the scariest platform because
your control this part of it like your
swing in and you're controlling both
brothers at the same time and you don't
like wait wait which guy do I have
control itchin it's gonna take you a
while to figure out those control
there's just trying to be patient I mean
it's it's just incredible game so I
recommend playing brothers all these
games are like and I have mentioned
today are great games this game of the
year Michael the last of us myself with
brothers a tale of two sons these are
all games you should check out a lot of
good sales moc pc owners or steam xbox
and ps3 and ps4 have done a really good
job of reducing their prices for sale so
look for all these games that we
mentioned today of course this isn't the
final list there's other games to play
there's still come under your top games
of the year 2013 we're looking forward
to in 2014 coming up with the new
systems a next gen gen you know let us
know what you think you know as always
you come chat with us at think yo calm
he also finds on this youtube page at
think hero pro gonna come chat with
dennis michael myself about what games
were playing we're always playing a new
game always checking something out
Dennis just got a ps3 you know what
she's been playing so ask him about
those at think hero i'm at griffin de
now i'm at mr. michael Alexis and also
we have a Facebook page has facebook com
so I stink hero fans give us a like
subscribe for the word
you know a video game you know it's just
great great year for video games great
time for video game so yeah